bonjour et merci d'avoir poser toutes
vos questions sur les épisodes 7 et 8
que vous avez pu voir hier soir on m'a
dit finalement ça vous a plu beaucoup
beaucoup de réactions très enthousiaste
et c'est très agréable je vais avouer
que ça en soleil mon confinement donc je
vais essayer de répondre à quelques unes
de vos questions pas tout parce qu'elle
a beaucoup donc voilà on va partir pour
une petite séance d'éclairage
bon alors toutes les planches ne sont
pas aménagés en studios avec une
c'est ce qu'on appelait le studio
musique c'est une des planques de la
dgse
enfin dans dans le film va dans dans la
série et on imagine que d'autres plantes
comme ça sont aménagés dans d'autres
genres que un studio musique
alors en fait c'est l'idée c'est que on
puisse justifier pour les voisins pour
les gens qui passent comme ça on peut il
justifier des allées et venues sans que
ça soulève trop de doute trop de
soupçons sans que ça attire l'attention
donc un studio musique on voit des gens
qui arrivent avec des instruments de
musique qui vont qui viennent ça ça
tourne beaucoup là-dedans
donc c'est pas mal personne ne se pose
la question quand on voit des gens
différents entrer là dedans on peut même
arriver des camionnettes
d'ailleurs on l'a on l'a montré dans la
saison je crois par les idées qu'elle
est et faire monter des gens dedans ou
se faire sortir en tant que danseur
musique donc en fait là un type de
plante qui justifie les allées et venues
c'est pas mal
je dois avouer que c'est pas une volonté
par contre c'est peut-être une logique
là dessous d'abord à d'abord concis dans
ces propos c'est très important dans ce
type de métier d'être très très précis
et ça dans l'écriture des dialogues on a
vraiment fait attention à ça et même
dans le jeu des acteurs enfin dans la
direction d'acteurs
c'était quelque chose qui était très
important c'est que vraiment
je disais souvent il s'agit de bien
comprendre ce que ce que les gens se
disent parce que vies sont en jeu en
général des opérations entière peuvent
peuvent s'écrouler parce que une
instruction a été mal interprétés donc
je pense que la concision la rigueur du
langage la précision du langage est très
importante et vous a beaucoup d'idées
dans l'écriture des dialogues et dans la
direction d'acteurs
ensuite les propos paternaliste ou même
la légaux l'aller les allégories dans ça
on n'a pas fait exprès c'est c'est
l'action c'est la dramaturgie qui
pourrait appeler ça
jouer restent respectivement par anatoly
pantchenko bac hà tinh et alex et
gorbunov karloff alors karloff c'est un
acteur connu d'excellents acteurs qu
avec qui j'avais déjà travaillé sur mon
film mobius et que j'avais découvert
dans le film 12 de mikhalkov qui était
tout de suite j'ai vu que c'était un
acteur absolument extraordinaire et donc
voilà lui il est connu alors anatoly
pantchenko par et non pas par contre est
absolument inconnu et et une petite
anecdote assez assez drôle je sais de la
résumer assez longue
il était en galère et l origine de file
et ukrainiens il a beaucoup
il a travaillé sur des bateaux sur des
navires comme ça et sa vie et puis son
bref c'était d'être acteur et il avait
un il avait gagné assez d'argent pour
réaliser son rêve est allé à los angeles
pour faire une école d'acteurs là il
essayait de trouver quand même des
petits boulots pour moi
pour travailler et il a cherché à être
assistant directeur de casting ont guidé
dans le bureau d'un directeur de casting
en train d'essayer d'avoir un boulot
d'assistant quand le téléphone a sonné
sur le bureau le directeur de casting a
pris son téléphone et là c'était jj à
conca ma directrice de casting qui dure
qu'il appelait qu'elle le connaissait
pour lui dire 'est-ce que tu connais pas
des jeunes de entre 25 et 30 ans qui
parle anglais et russes et qu'ils soient
bien donc le type il a levé les yeux sur
un atelier qui était en face de lui les
jeudis
tu as entre 25 et 30 ans tu parle
anglais et et par le russe ben tu vas
faire une petite vidéo parce que
quelqu'un qui cherche quelqu'un comme
toi voilà il a envoyé sa vidéo et tout
de suite on a trouvé que il était
formidable
ces acteurs absolument formidable
je dirais un peu des deux il est
schizophrène parce qu'il entend des voix
c'est assez je crois typique de
schizophrénie paranoïde une certaine
manière mais en fait les paranos et ça
c'est un principe d'écriture qu'on a
toujours suivi souvent sur des jantes
etc en fait les paranos ont toujours
raison
ils ont toujours raison de penser qu'on
leur en veut en général surtout parce
que c'est eux qui se débrouille pour
qu'on leur en veuille donc ils le savent
c'est pas qu'il pense que les gens leur
en veulent c'est qu'en fait ils savent
on leur en veux
[Musique]
donc les paranos d'une création très
utile dans le domaine de la sécurité
intérieure de la dgse ou d'autres
d'autres entités d'ailleurs
j'ai envie de dire au contraire le
recrutement de carlos et se fait sur la
base que il a fait des erreurs il a
introduit deux agents doubles au sein du
fsb malotru et césar donc c'est une
vraie après talent d'achille c'est
vraiment ce qu'on peut lui reprocher sa
hiérarchie va lui reprocher si la ciel
le sait va lui reprocher et va
probablement l'exil
l'emprisonner exécuté en pensant qu'il a
fait exprès donc au moment où on va lui
présenter ces raisons là pour leur côté
au moment où à lui dire voilà on veut
passer un deal avec toi sois du travail
pour nous soit on rêvait la théière
archi ces deux erreurs dans ta carrière
est bien à ce moment là il peut avoir
une réaction qui est déjà de faire
arrêter des agents doubles donc les
agents doubles il faut les les mettre à
l'abri
malotru est à l'abri parce qu'il est
c'est lui qui va le recruter donc il est
protégé par toute une équipe est
sûrement par toute une organisation
mais pacemaker lui il faut l'exfiltrer
alors l'exfiltrer ça veut dire le faire
sortir du jeu sans qu'on pense qu'il est
exfiltré par une par une agence de
renseignement bien sûr il faut pas le
griller il faut bon il faut qu'on pense
par exemple qu'il est complètement
déprimée et kid a et qu'il a décidé de
rentrer chez lui la fille qui travaille
avec lui pardonne tout paksas à sa
supérieure hiérarchique va penser que en
fait voilà il a craqué et s'est pas
tellement qu'il a qu'il était un agent
double en fait il faut il faut le faire
sortir du jeu sans révéler qu'il était
un agent double et c'est ça qui est
important
et donc c'est ça qui se passe donc c'est
au contraire nécessaire de protéger de
protéger césar à ce moment là justement
pour que le recrutement de tarnow réussi
et bien en fait malotru ne veux pas a
priori mêlée la dgs à sa relation avec
nadia il veut il veut s'en occuper lui
même il veut pas que sa tâche que ça
entache que ça salit ce que ça que ça
complique
et surtout il veut pas que gia vienne
mettre son nez dans cette relation qu'il
est en train de reconstruire de certaine
manière de reconstruire sur des bases
plutôt saine que sont les bases
finalement de la sincérité de
l'honnêteté
donc si il a une chance de pouvoir se
sort enfin doit reconstruire cette
relation
il pense qu'il ne faut pas du tout la
dgsi mettre son nez donc ils n'en
parlent pas c'est lui qui va se
débrouiller
évidemment il va être obligé m comme
d'habitude à chaque fois ils pensent
pouvoir maîtriser la situation puis
finalement ils ne maîtrisent pas et puis
finalement il y arrive quand même
eh bien le passage de ramsès donc
l'officier du renseignement égyptien
dans l'épisode 5 je crois au l'épisode 6
marie-jeanne lui montre des micros qui
est dans sa chambre en pensant que c'est
lui qui les a mis donc il ne dit rien il
fait il avale sa couleuvres et puis
descend et puis 10 leçons son collègue
dans la voiture il y a quelqu'un qui
avait des micros dans la chambre cette
dame et j'aimerais bien savoir qui parce
que ça n'est pas nous voilà donc ça
c'est si vous voulez c'est juste le
début d'un fils conac on n'a pas tiré
qu'on n'a pas été voir on n'a pas vu
nous mêmes mais en tout cas on comprend
que à partir de là ils ont finalement
réussi à savoir attirer le fil
en ce sens une enquête puisque ensuite
on voit pas dans le jeune salim en train
de discuter avec un jihadiste dans un
café ou un moment donné on sent une
enquête ils ont ils ont réussi
finalement à griller ce réseau à les
laisser aller observer les effets et en
décidant d arrêter tous voire de les
tuer tous au moment de l'attaqué
voilà donc cette scène là et d'ailleurs
cette ligne narrative qui est des micro
permet de comprendre avec une vraie
ellipses permet de comprendre comment
finalement ils ont su pour l'attak
j'aimerais bien
c'est un travail absolument énorme c'est
ce travail sur la musique sur la saison
5 est ce qui s'est passé en plus d'un
par rapport aux saisons précédentes
d'abord on a on a on alors qu'elle n'a
fait jouer un orchestre
robin a fait des arrêts à faire des
arrangements et ensuite on a un vrai
encaissent des vraies cordes ça ça
vraiment ça et au fait on se dit voilà
pour cette saison là on va y aller on va
mettre le paquet donc les thèmes que rob
avait les thèmes que rob avait qu'ils
ont développées dans les saisons
précédentes la elles ont été laissées
thème là ont été retravaillés et comme
ça me booste et par par la présence de
cet orchestre
et puis comme vous avez pu voir il ya eu
un travail très précis sur les épisodes
7 et 8 et 6 7 et 8 mais surtout sur
l'épisode 8 ou là moi j'ai voulu en fait
j'aime été on avait été très
impressionné par la musique sur le film
el rey hinault l'espagne est un
formidable et
et donc j'avais été impressionné par
leur usage de cette musique là et j'ai
dit et on va essayer de faire la même
chose sur les épisodes épisode 8 parce
que je savais qu'il y avait à voir toute
une partie comme ça où on allait suivre
on allait suivre vraiment très proche
d'elle on allait suivre nadia
avec toujours ce danger que nadia se
fasse arrêter à cause de cette histoire
de recrutement et que laisse à
tout en l'air
voilà ça je savais assez tôt que le pire
de 8 allée tourner autour autour de ça
et donc j'avais vraiment envie que il ya
une musique qui accompagne et ça c'est
vraiment très très différent de ce qu'on
a tout ce qu'on a fait sur le bureau des
gens d'avant sa musique un peu de techno
comme ça un beat très fort important
avec différentes variations un peu
angoissante
dessus et c'est un peu la demande que
j'avais fait à rome
peu après c'est bien démerdé on a
beaucoup travaillé on a beaucoup
amélioré
on travaille on travaille vraiment main
dans la main pour la musique de cette
série
[Musique]
pas sûr alors je savais que la saison 5
serait ma dernière
je décide et même de plonger dans
l'écriture dans la fabrication de cette
saison 5
finalement presque à condition que c'est
ma dernière car c'était assez quand même
là c'est difficile après saison 4
c'était faut trouver l'inspiration faut
faut savoir ce qu'on ce qu'on fait il
faut garder d' enthousiasme
donc moi je me suis dit ok on va on va
essayer d'avoir l'aspiration voici
d'abord enthousiasme mais voilà encore
une saison pas après ça risque
ça risque de redescendre lentement
précise on travaille là dessus donc je
savais que c'était ma dernière saison
est ce que j'ai conçu les épisodes en
fonction de sa non j'ai continué j'ai
conçu les épisodes en fonction d'une
trame à turgis déjà je suis pas seul
nous avons conçu les épisodes en
fonction d'une dramaturgie qui était
éric irritait les de tout ce qu'on avait
fait les saisons précédentes
et justement je n'ai pas voulu trop
elle sentimentale maîtres de maîtres de
mon rapport à la série dans les
histoires ça n'a rien à voir les
malotrus marina marie-jeanne sisteron
gia n'ont rien à faire de du fait que
j'ai que j'ai écrits où je conçois la
série c'est pas leur problème et je
voulais pas que ce soit leurs problèmes
donc je voulais pas trop finalement
mètres de moi même ou maître de mon
rapport à la série dans l'histoire et
dans l'écriture et d'ailleurs c'est bien
pour ça que c'est pas moi qui vais
terminer cette série c'est pas moi qui
vais terminer cette saison mais c'est
jacques audiard le grand jacques audiard
qui va qui va finalement clore cette
saison
d'ailleurs souvenir que je garde de
cette série sur l' aventure extrêmement
dense qui a duré six ans puisqu'on a
commencé à écrire un début juin 2013
sept ans et on verra bien jusqu'ici
donc c'est très difficile quand même
deux
d'avoir un meilleur souvenir général et
souvenirs qu'on a c'est ceux d'hier
entière est sous contrôle
donc on se souvient donc je dois vous
dire que hier soir au moment de la
diffusion des deux épisodes 7 et 8 qui
sont finalement mes deux derniers en
tant que showrunner en tant que
réalisateur aussi et bien
j'ai senti vraiment une vibration c'est
pas con c'est pas facile parce qu'en
fait quand on fait un film on fait des
projections
donc si on fait un film un peu drôle on
entend les temps les gens rire si on
fait un film tendu quand même on sent la
tension dans la salle quand on fait une
série là encore pire en confinement je
veux dire qu'on voit rien du tout on
sent rien on voit rien
voilà rien n'est concret alors donc du
coup les réactions tant le messager
réactions sur internet
tout ce que je peux lire
et là qui est un peu en direct jeu
presque comme si c'était une projection
finalement une projection numérique
digital les réactions en direct sur la
diffusion des deux épisodes d'hier a été
un moment fort un moment très fort parce
que voilà j'ai été à 10 ans ils ont ils
ont fonctionné comme on voulait qu'il
fonctionne et ça c'est une vraie
récompense voilà qu'on repense à force
ça marche quand ça fonctionne quand les
gens reçoivent un peu près ce qu'on a
voulu mettre dans les pilotes ça
fonctionne donc ça c'est le souvenir le
plus immédiat et ben sinon j'ai le vrai
j'ai à peu près tout est oublié
voilà donc je voulais vous remercier
encore d'avoir posé toutes ces questions
je voudrais me remercier aussi d'avoir
partager votre enthousiasme
je pense que donc vous allez avoir
beaucoup de questions à poser encore sur
les deux derniers épisodes et
éventuellement d'ailleurs ça va
peut-être peut-être et de l'occasion
aussi de poser des questions sur
l'ensemble de la série et donc des cinq
saisons donc est possible qu'on fasse
une petite séance un peu spéciale la
semaine prochaine
voilà donc écouter bonne semaine de
confinement à tous
et puis je vous donne rendez vous donc à
l'un des prochains
enfin mardi prochain